[Music]
wait a minute like to propose a toast to
my family someday so you can have
families of your own and if you're lucky
you'll remember the little moments like
this
now what good cheese
well this a awesome Carter and get tough
you're listening to the good times right
now
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll worry about a thing
open it
[Music]
you
what's up Lee hey guys this is Simone
and you're listening in the good times
with Steve Simone and my buddy leaves
making this extra special because we're
not in the studio studio together I know
this is a line I call lose like it's
more fun when I call in yeah it's like
before the Internet in kid I used to
talk to kids on the phone about homework
like before impotent messenger came out
it just seems so fun yeah it's so much
fun phone calls sometimes are fun I
don't normally like talking on the phone
but if it's you if it's and it's fun for
some reason right now and speaking of
fun we have to make this short because
guess what what's happening this is why
I'm calling in because I have to I'm
this Sunday when we normally do this I'm
going to be in Philly hanging out with
my family which is awesome
and then right now I'm at my house and
Artie's coming over Brodie might come
over Brian O'Neill from Danish and
O'Neill might come over so we're just
hanging out and having had him last so
there wasn't enough time to have some
laps and then make it to the studio so
thank you so much for doing this for me
Lee oh and thank you guys for listening
of course this is so much fun this is
great this is a I feel I feel like I'm
in like it may be moving outer space or
something right now maybe no you're in
outer space like I just I just imagine
how it's different right it does and I
saw to you today is really quick there
were like I don't know if it was
elementary or what it was but there were
these kids walking with their teachers
and each kid has like a buddy and they
were singing like I think was a twine
mice or something and they were just
walking down the tree line three blind
mice 800 I don't know why I thought I
was eight three blind mice and it would
just we're just having the best time and
it made me think of a good times yes the
absolute greatest three blind mice makes
me think of the three stooges
and I took my friend dolly up to this
place it's like the old folks home for
people at work in showbiz O'Hara and I
held my friendship yeah and my friend
Jordan was like yeah you know all Three
Stooges went there and I was like yes I
did and I didn't realize my friend Jordy
like Three Stooges as much as I
it we could do an all Three Stooges
episode of good times that would be
wonderful
now that would make my dad I admit that
that used to be my favorite part of
about New Year's Eve because they always
they play them like all day tree Stooges
marathon that's a good memory that's
fantastic oh I can't thank father Greg
run is easy enough for doing last week's
episode of good times we I've got more
positive feedback off of that and I
think any episode I've done that's
amazing that's know and it was really
really cool it's cool that like to me
the coolest part is just that he liked
Steve's brother so you use your friends
with both of them and they're so
different but similar it's funny it's
awesome it's like I I'm friends with the
Juliana brothers my buddy Brian is like
a head baseball coach and then his
brothers like the top jazz drummer in
the world you know what I mean like it's
just so cool how like families have so
much in common but then everybody has
their unique talents that they share
with the world the absolute best and
it's so cool that they both got to do it
on good times
yeah for sure dude this episode okay I
got to make this quick Joe Sid who just
released an album a comedy album called
nowhere near the top Joseph isn't not
only a comedian he's also a musician so
he's an artist businessman he owns side
one dummy records which is one of the
top punk rock labels in the world but
more importantly he's a family man and
that's what I love most about them and
this episode was so cool cause like I
was always afraid of kids that listen to
punk rock and stuff like that any
explain you know what what exactly punk
rock is and what it was like growing up
in California in that like totally cool
kid scene and then he starts talking
about comedy and being a dad it's one of
my favorite episodes I'm so grateful for
all these episodes so let's get into
this week's episode with Joe save and
come back and do the gratitude look I
love you guys thank you so much for
listening to good times this week with
my buddy mr. Joe SID
well that's what I want to say first off
deregulation house is beautiful the
neighborhood's amazing I can't believe I
live here but more importantly it's one
of the few homes I've been in in Los
Angeles and there's a difference I've
been a killer pad man but very few homes
so congratulations I think I think I
think the vibe just that's what success
is yeah and right away I was like oh my
god this feels like a John Hughes movie
this feel you know and then all my
daughter's friends running around there
cases of cokes 200 kids are going to be
here don't say that
do you think do you think what did I get
what did I get myself into good times if
you're making memories this is great
like how does your honor when I was 15
that's what I figured but you know what
dude she is such I don't know I mean I
know you well enough to know family
that's ever East Coast yeah the whole
thing so you remember as a kid did
barbecues the greatest they were the
best right yeah you know the thing that
we've had in our family since I was a
little kid was uh my parents threw big
parties yeah whether it was a baptism
whether it was Thanksgiving whether it
was a holiday dinner whether it was a
love the rational life it's her last day
of school she's worked so hard she
planned this dude I'm telling you right
now she told me I go hey music's got to
be over at 10 o'clock and she's on no I
go what are you talking about Shawn
according to and she reads a part off of
the the the the city police that he
where we live you can play music loud
till 11:00 that's Fantas say or so savvy
and then she told me about the whole I
go well hey you know I you know
obviously I'm like there's no alcohol
right she's like dad yeah I know that
and I go okay so how does how does it
work if the party gets out of control
and we're here you know because the way
it works is that she basically said to
me dad I want to have a party okay and I
was stoked yeah I was like awesome honey
and I'm like I'll get the PA we'll get
the whole thing going oh my gosh really
dad we can do it again
and then she said what about food I go
we'll do that so I'm getting all handled
and then she's like she literally says
dad one more thing I know anything she's
like can you not come to the party
hahahahahah says that oh my god I get a
sweet memory yeah but you know who is
invited is my wife get out of here yeah
so my wife and my nephew they came down
from Northern California so they arrived
last night which is awesome my niece is
here who you met about my nephew he's 22
today oh happy birthday honey and then
and my wife so all three of them are in
charge as the the chaperone supervision
and then you're ready for this my wife
got super super rad and went next door
to our neighbor um who basically we've
known him since he was 17 and I used to
get mad at him for having ragers I'd be
like hey dude that's a super cool parent
and I'm a cool neighborhood but then I
have a little guys yeah I've now you
know what I did I employed him he's
working security for the part I was
going to ask you about that
that's smart yeah so there you go it's
necessary yeah and you're going to be
monitoring it too right because your dad
you know what dude I'm you're not going
to be there you're not going to violate
her trust but you know where you have
your dad traps you know what you you met
her guitar
what was shaving she was sweeping and
ending things and I was just like you
know what I remember being that age and
I was like you know what go for it just
where were you at 15 oh gosh 15 for me
was I had just left Santa Cruz cuz I
grew up in Santa Cruz California I heard
that's the buddy of mine who's a
professional strong with him oh but he
grew up in Santa Cruz and he was like
the hippie cool Beach awesome he's like
that's real California yeah he was like
dude you have to go check out it gets so
expensive now buddy yeah
have to go check I would I was super
lucky my my parents lived there when I
was a little kid you know so I grew up
in the mountains my whole background was
like I was this kid that we grew we I
grew up on five acres in the middle of
nowhere in the redwood trees yeah which
it's so crazy now to look back on it
because I would love to live like that
but when I was that age I couldn't stand
it I was
boryang I was a city kid yeah I was
looking for cement to skateboard on did
you guys did you spend any of your
childhood in Philly or was that just
where your parents made me there and uh
my dad was from Queens
my mom our I'm sorry my dad from Forest
Hills okay my mom from Philadelphia they
met on a cruise during like a Spring
Break thing oh my god yeah and then they
basically they basically were like I was
always joke around I was made there but
within two weeks after I was born they
were already planning on moving in
California took me out here so that's
why I always get amazing you know like a
lot of people will be like oh man
your East Coast right and I'm like no I
you know I look at ya until like I start
to talk and then people are like oh my
gosh you are so California Oh California
yeah but yeah so you know growing up I
was growing up in Santa Cruz growing up
in the middle of nowhere then you know
as a lot of parents did in the 80s my
parents got divorced yeah so basically
that was our generation yeah are you
still together they're still together
grazie they're like Costanza's parents
or ray Romano's parents or Everybody
Loves Raymond but they're I admire them
so much the older I get the more I
admire that oh yeah I'm like just
something me said for sticking it out
you know what I mean yeah I mean my wife
and I've been together we're on our 19th
anniversary of being married that's
amazing and then throw in seven years
dating before then we've been together
26 years it's like a hundred years for
our generation Jude we people send us
awards that we don't even know they're
just like we heard you're still together
thank you
what's the secret uh what is the secret
I this is this is this is you know what
it is the reason her and I are still
together is we laugh a lot and we don't
we were able to call each other out on
our bond are just on art like can we
swear yeah yeah um she can call me out
on my [__] and I'll be like no I'm
not like that or oh I didn't mean that
or and then she's the only she there's
two people in my life they can call me
out on my [__] and I'll come back
around and go you know what you're
totally right well that would be my wife
Karen and then
my partner bill who I started side one
with that it's so cool you know and I
just we've been together that long you
know we were talking about it the other
day we were laughing because we've been
together so long and in your
relationship it's crazy dude it's like
you know when we first met I was I was
23 years old she was 22 Wow and you know
you stayed here his kids like jeez my
kid however being 22 and I thought I had
everything figured out do like the 18 to
22 or the years where I thought life
made the most sense I mean literally we
got together when we were kids and
you're not supposed to stay together
with the person that you meet at the
Linda's doll Hut off of the five freeway
in Santa Ana
not where you meet your wife or your
husband and you and I met her there were
you playing in a band I was in a band
under my bed wax and we were doing a gig
there and she was shooting pool and I
just got done rocking to the 12 people
that were there yeah you know and I went
over and I was like I'm uh I'm gonna
hang I'm gonna try to meet her she just
wanted nothing to do with me
she I she's like you're that dude on
stage that freaks out I was like what do
you mean I would that's not saying I'm
in my band and she's like I don't know
and then you know just you know you got
our number that night oh you know I know
I actually did this maneuver I actually
jumped that everyone's going to an
after-party and I'm like hey I'm gonna
get a ride with you and I jumped in her
car she's like what are you doing get
out of my car I'm like on the way give
me a ride let's go to the party with you
I swear and she's like all right and
there was our bass player was with her
girlfriend they were kind of hanging out
yeah so we got the ride to the party and
then the party ended and everyone was
jamming back to Hollywood or Long Beach
and I remember I'm like let's go I'll go
with you to Long Beach and she's like
what are you talking about then like we
go to Long Beach I remember and at that
time it was such an awkward moment and
she still talked about we go to this
house there's no furniture it's like one
of those houses were like everyone has a
room but there's no like yeah it's not a
house yeah yeah and we show up and I
remember the girl that was hooking up
with my bro they just immediately go
into the bedroom and it sounds like
they're weightlifting in there you know
and then I'm like okay now what we're in
a we're in a dark living room with like
one light and then she came back out the
woman
like are the girl and like through us
like two sleeping bags in a pillow and I
remember I just it was like 3:00 in the
morning I'm like look I swear I won't
bust a move on you and like we need you
know we had to sleep yeah and it's
freezing because it's the middle of
winter and we both like I laid down the
the comforter because we only had one
and I was like you know you know I swear
I won't bust a move she's like all right
and I didn't and I remember I remember
like later on in the relationship she
was like I was that night I was tripping
out like why didn't this guy make a move
like haha you told me not to yeah what's
up with this guy you know as I got and
then I got a ride back to Hollywood
Hollywood with her and then we went out
to el compadre what that was our first
date not to kill her first day yeah Isis
grab her for the folks who are listening
that aren't in LA that's like this is a
restaurant right on Sunset Boulevard
custard from Guitar Center it's right in
the middle rock and roll section yeah
and you know at that time you're talking
the early 90s oh is happening and they
had flaming margaritas in there the food
will it's like it gives you like
botulism yeah but uh it was such a great
scene and that was our first date and
and we've been together ever since
Wow that's off which is a trip that's so
old-school
I know it's weird that's awesome yeah
yeah we've been together we feed now
we've been together almost I think
longer than we haven't you know it's
crazy so cool yeah can't believe it
that's such a rare thing I don't think
because I don't think people want to
make the sacrifices to keep it going
dude I think it's just because I've
always done the opposite of everything
around me like my parents got divorced
I'm like I'm gonna stay together forever
yeah you know uh that was always you
know my dad you know like even like you
know even down to little things like I
think when I got the nickname SID yes
you know my last name is really severe
and oh okay and I remember I got this
kid in high school was like I just met
him I moved when I moved in with my dad
okay I show up my mom don't worry both
your parents in the Santa Cruz area or
did yeah they're both in Santa Cruz
Northern California my dad's super super
smart intellectual start out as an
English professor Santa Clara University
worked up to Dean of Arts
science at Santa Clara University then
went on to st. Mary's College and from
there was part of the Art Institute in
Chicago Wow from there I went back to
California to UOP I think it was and
then he ended up settling in San
Francisco up until this year at a place
called a CI is California insured
integral institute of studies Wow which
is like just people that go to school
forever and take classes on everything
from help I got a think tank on mom
I mean they're doing so much the last
project he was a part of was using acid
to help people with disorders you know
get through it
Wow and I've never taken acid neither as
he and I was like dad if can we take
let's take acid together and her science
yeah and he just looked at me goes um
now we're not going to do that which I
get I've never done have you ever taken
acid yeah you and I are such to say yeah
I graviton it yeah yeah I know I'm a
nerd I smoked weed once freaked out yeah
yeah pizzas my drug of choice oh dude
that's what I say all the time do you
really say that yeah I have pictures on
my phone this mine thing is making
homemade pizza oh my goood I make
homemade pizza for my son in his Bros on
the pita bread they hit sell at Trader
Joe's that's like it's the pita bread
that's the the whole-wheat pita bread
and then I get the sauce and I do these
individual pieces great come over on
Friday nights and they'll ask me to make
them like mr. Civ and then I'll make
them and they're like this one kid he
wedges so many of them I'm like dude
you're never gonna take a [__] again
it's hot you just blocked up bro it's
it's a dud like I will see you for six
months due to temp like you have the fun
house we grew we cut in that the wind
yeah that's the ultimate yeah that's the
winner circle in the game of life yeah
where your kids are good people they're
making good friends I didn't say that
okay you ever hung out with him yet yeah
yeah before we said they're there
they're there in I would say they're
there in society when they're out of
their own there they're good suppose we
want inside that house that's my point
though that was not only wrong
written contract we had with our parents
yeah we're like we will represent you as
best as possible outside of these four
walls yeah we'll be polite we will be
kind yeah we will be good students we
will try our best to stay out of trouble
love with boys like yeah there were some
issues well you know and also like once
you're all underneath the same roof and
door shut hey yeah it was like
Thunderdome I feel like sometimes in my
house because my son plays music
constantly he's a great singer great
piano player and I'm really into music
and my daughter she's academics you know
and I played music my whole entire life
but like not like this guy like you know
he's he's a singer he's a you know he
can play piano I can't play piano I can
strum chords on the guitar I can you
know take my shirt off and dive into the
crowd like that but that's like that was
my vibe uh his his thing so it's like
there's always this tug of war in our
household where it's like you know my
daughter's trying to study he's trying
to write a jam my wife's in the middle
of it somewhere I'm here it sounds like
I always joke around it our house sounds
like backstage like I always feel like
I'm it I always feel like I'm at a
soundcheck
at my house always like our house just
feels like entertainment is going on
because like my daughter's kind of more
of that like if I would give her the the
analogy would be like you're backstage
at a club and my son soundchecking and
then my daughter is his like acting is
like some sort of manager arguing with
the owner of the club which would be my
wife so this is this guy a back and
forth and infinichi Lea yeah
and I'm in the middle of it - what's it
like seeing little not only making
little people but watching them grow
into the person they are now that's got
to be the like I think there's certain
things in life that we just don't think
about because they're so intense our
brains would explode yeah I mean the
tribulus thing is is that and I say it
all the time is that I didn't know what
was there you know just watching the
last shot that we're taping something
right now that's awesome come on through
tomatoes out of the show yes you can go
get it yeah this is good this is the
most fun stuff ever
yeah all right what was this close the
question what was the question okay
there you go
sick that's awesome it really is like a
John Hughes movie yeah I mean she was
looking for the ice chest ah there you
go I mean that's an example that she's I
remember when she was this little teeny
person that I had a help with every
single thing and I a member and I you
know the people listening right now I
was like wow I didn't know there's going
to be a parenting episode but it's it's
a having kids all I can say is that it
it softens your heart like before you
have kids and just cruising in the world
not really concerned with anything and
if you are you're way better person than
I am I was just concerned with my own
personal you know journey whatever I was
at the time you know I'm married at that
time and I'm like oh I got this company
I'm going to focus on that but you don't
start worrying about the future and and
the decisions that are being made around
us and I ain't I mean all of the things
that I never considered of interest or
of importance once you have kids you
start thinking about those things what
am I going to leave behind for them
exactly Wow now the environment really
matter exactly he doesn't have to last
another 40 50 years it's going to last
another 80 years yeah and then you start
thinking about what world they're living
in and that takes on a whole amount like
I was I was kidding around the day that
like you know someone's like wow man you
look like you lost weight and I was like
yeah because I'm on a steady diet of
anxiety and caffeine you know it's like
I'm worried and I'm also trying to keep
up with everything that's going on
around me
ah but you know at some point you must
just have to surrender yeah it's got to
be at some point like they're scared
like I just how much of a lunatic Guinea
I am I'm like if I have kids that first
day of school it's going to be how do
you like I don't I'm not emotionally
prepared for it
how yeah I mean yeah and when your kids
are teenagers like I I appreciate my
parents more and more the older I get
and I'm like how did you let me get into
a car with a 16 year old kid yeah I know
I think about well you know what someone
said something to me when I went with
parenting they said hey when you're a
parent don't be afraid to be a hypocrite
and I made a lot of sense because I I've
actually kind of fun yeah I was because
my kids will come to me and they'll say
to me you know when I was 15 years old
my dad was living with my dad he was
allowing me to go I lived in San Jose
and I would go and spend the entire
weekend in Berkeley which was you know
pretty central yeah but it was also like
7080 miles away from our home and not
only where I spend the weekend there but
all I would do is while I was in
Berkeley I was just taking the bus
everyday into San Francisco and staying
there to 3:00 in the morning then going
back to Berkeley and the way that we
even got to Berkeley in 15 though the
way that we got to Berkeley was on the
BART so you know you take three buses to
get to BART and then you get on the BART
for an hour going up to Berkeley and the
reason that we were going up there was
because at that moment punk rock was
just hitting the suburbs so every band
from Black Flag to the Circle Jerks to
Minor Threat to youth Brigade you name
it they were all coming through the Bay
Area so I was on I was just on the front
line of this and I and I was so when I
was like punk rock and skateboarding
were just like those are the two things
that just drove me so all of a sudden my
dad when I move in with him I'm 15 I
might have to live it yeah my dad also
was because he had traveled in Europe so
much he was very used to like yeah kids
in Europe go to the pub kids in Europe
go to shows so yeah you want to go with
your friends you know let give me a
number away you're going to be at but
back then dude you know cell phone yeah
there's a number and I remember I
remember I would he would just ask and
this is crazy
he would ask you know check in with me
while you're up there but it wasn't like
wow check in every day he'd be like you
know I'm sure I called him on like
Saturday and I saw everybody crashing we
were there was a it was funny there was
another family these these two girls
that were like kind of basically sisters
their dad owned that their mom and dad
owned this house and they had they had
the attic to themselves what the cool
check yeah I can still remember I wish
right now I could plug like a fire wire
into my head I remember I was I was
walking up I get off of it we get off of
the train station probably attic in
Berkeley and we have our skateboards and
my friend who is bringing me up those
kills your friend Shawn Palmer how did
you guys become buddies his he was he
was one of the first he was the first
punk rocker I met
he had a double mohawk and he was the
first punk rocker I met that was punk
rock but also he was taking French and
Spanish and geometry and he was super
smart that is awesome and also you know
I took an ambitious punk rock like yet
it's yet an act together yeah he was
ambition but also he was the first kid
that I met so I mean all these kids at
this high school and talk about just you
know wow this is insane I go from like
Santa Cruz little beach town to
literally my mom saying you can't live
here anymore you got to go stay with
your father on us on a Saturday morning
to going to a new high school on a
Monday Wow yeah all during I was 15 I
was a sophomore in high school and I
remember my dad was so so like you know
just like yeah come live with me like it
wasn't even a question
here's a go yeah okay just grab whatever
you need because he was always there
every weekend to visit me so it wasn't a
big he's like you know I don't you know
I don't mind you moving in so I move in
with him were you already in a punk rock
at that point oh yeah but like punk rock
to me at that point Steve was like was
like Levi's with like converse and a
flannel short hair you know like I had
you know and then the first day I go to
this school Westmont high I walk in and
I remember I first of all I was from a
student body of say a few hundred all of
a sudden I was at a student body of say
a thousand you know yeah now you're
gonna like one of those high yes you see
in Poovey suit full high school in the
movie I was right like whoa cliques and
this and that how am I going to fit in
and I'm 15 and yeah and
and I have my flannel on in my
skateboard and my vans and I'm like okay
cool you know like how's this going to
work and I remember as I'm walking in I
this kid with a leather leather jacket
the word discharge written on the back
studs full blond spiky hair peg Levi's a
pair of creepers on um you know and I
was like well I'm like look at this kid
and I was like whoa dude like I've never
seen punk rock like whoa yeah I mean
I've seen it he from my magazine yelled
you so much okay I'm from the punk and
disorderly cover there was a stack
where's this punk rock record that it
came out called punk disorderly and I
remember like there was a dude there was
dudes like that on it and I was like
holy like dude is that is that one of
the guys yeah and I remember he's
looking at me and and there was just
this unspoken thing of like like he and
he was getting detention they're like
you know mr. trumpeter I gotta still
remembers named Joe trumpeter you know
mr. trumpeter you're gonna have to do
he's like yeah he was just like whatever
and he kind of walks by me and I kind of
look at him and then I remember I go to
my first class that day and it's
woodshop it could be a good job which is
like prison is that kids are making
shanks and fawn I loved what job mr. so
sure dude I had mr. wood arson he was
missing a finger oh yeah yeah that's
perfect that's a gentle you want a
finger and he call everyone look look he
did have this create like he called it
look you go over there you got to use it
put a stick in there you get kickback
you know how they got to talk about the
ban and I would dude I was so and I
still AM I was so scared of any type of
power tools like that I I don't even
know how I passed the class because you
had ease band saw and you had to use the
table saw and I was like [__] bat and
on top of it all the kids are in the
class they're all like you know the firt
like it wasn't like I went into a
classroom setting I'm in this room and
like you know of course it is a class he
kind of you know gives out the
assignment then these kids cruise around
me like hey man who are you we ran from
it's like a prison yard
dude it's dude some like you know I'm
like okay here we go and they were cool
and then we had and then the next thing
is we have this break so I'm like okay
what does that mean and everyone goes
out into this quad area and that's where
you see you know
the real division like okay the Jockey
guys are there the surfers over here but
there was this huge stage it was so
strange I'll never forget it West my
high it was still your first day this is
my first day Wow and this is their have
this huge stage it was a stage where
they might have had back in the day like
assemblies but on one side you had all
these long-haired metal like these kids
and do shirts and like motley crue and
they were in long hair they all look
like I swear they all look like Eddie
Van Halen's they all have little teeny
mustache because they'd never shaved
before and the feathered hair yeah and I
was like all right and I'm like looking
at those dudes and they were all smoking
yeah and then on the other side of the
stage directly across the military's
that was so funny
what's all the punkers so you had all
the dudes with that you had this crew
it's skateboarders and dudes with you
know mohawk and dudes with you know like
maybe they were like you know some kids
in the mod and then some rockabilly kids
like the music you know like a kid that
looked like he was in Duran Duran and
there was another kid but it was funny
because the kid that looked like he was
in Duran Duran was best friends with the
skinhead and the skinhead was best
friends with the dude that looked like
he was in bellos enough to there and it
was just like you're a freak I'm a freak
let's hang out
oh and for this particular break and
good enough they would all have smoked
cigarettes open act for some reason I'm
going I'm eating it I go to get like a
chocolate milk and I'm hanging out in
this Gold Club now his girl rolls up on
me and I her I remember she's like hey
and it's so crazy to say like this was
her introduction she's all hey do you
like punk rock and I go yeah and she's
all would you like to meet other people
that like punk rock Wow and I go okay
and that set me on the path that I have
followed along to my life from the bone
remember that girl's name
Tina guru I can't believe I remember
that Tina Grier she brought me over
there and she introduced me to this
whole crew people that basically became
the they were the Gateway like if
there's a gateway drug yeah they were
the Gateway people that the first
weekend hey man we're going to the on
Broadway in San Francisco what's that
I'd only go to San Francisco for Easter
yeah we go to Mass and they go to brunch
at
yeah they're like hey man you want to go
see the Circle Jerks
I'm like like the band that has the
record and they're like yeah and I'm
like like you're gonna go see that like
the transition of it leaving your
bedroom and actually touching it in the
real world totally dude I only got the
only concert I've ever gone to in my
entire life up into that moment Beach
Boys Candlestick Park Giants
doubleheader with my dad perfect I've
never seen a live band then after that
Beach Boys concert what was the first
show was it two circle Church it was the
circle it was the Circle Jerks
at the on Broadway or you know no the
first show the first show the first live
experience of any live music is at San
Jose City College Social Distortion
wow that's the first band I ever go see
and that's the first time that like I
like I don't even I remember I was so
clueless and I with with what even
socialist or ssin was that this kid that
was this older kid Craig Ramsay he was
in college in an amazing you can
remember I can't believe I remember
these names there but if you ask me like
what year my daughter was born after go
ask her I remember everything
it's it's like cinch get in this frame
of mind keep going
so anyway so with Craig Ramsay I
remember I'm skateboarding and I'm
hanging out and I'm down live with my
dad and I'm you know meeting all these
wonderful beautiful there are no
accidents like what a transition yeah
and and this this guy says hey you know
art are you going to go see Social
Distortion
and I didn't even know what that was I
was like how long had you been in the
school I was at this point you know this
I would been there you know like maybe
two months I was you know feeling it out
I was doing I was meeting a lot of kids
I was go to a lot at that point I was
going to a lot of I was going to a lot
of parties I was skating with these kids
there's a really great skate scene in
San Jose so I was I was really for two
more what deck you were riding at Oh at
that point um I was probably riding a
billy rough on gns an ordinance man yeah
yeah I loved that was like I had a billy
rough and then I remember
I had a Mike Smith into a Billy rough
into I had a gator at a certain point
Gator Division I had that one of the
all-time class and then I really you
know I was really Santa Cruz skateboards
was everything to me I had like you know
when Corey O'Brien's board came out I
got that you know just I think I had a
bob tonight board for a while I I mean
did those old decks are so valuable now
oh yeah the baseball card said yeah
right now absolutely absolutely you know
uh but they ended up going to this show
and this this guy was like hey and the
best part about him talking in a
socialist Ornstein was this is you know
there's no Google there's no iTunes
there's no there's all different man bro
you don't know he gets me to go he goes
hey man you should go see Social
Distortion and I said really and I'm
like I don't know and he goes why not I
go and I asked I go I don't know man
where do they sound like like I throw
that out he goes how they sound like and
he sings to me dude mommy's little
monster come on what's that he goes
mommy's little monster she's not a
friend gentlemen Jenna Mike won't do
that snarling and then he goes what
about this dude atom bomb
TNT I'm like dude I'll buy a ticket you
see me
yeah watch me the scene of Fast Times at
Ridgemont I went to moans trying to sell
the tickler Li hua she just she's yeah
yeah yeah you think it a dream police
yeah very good man though the voice of
Robin Zander the Mattia is so great such
a different world yeah
so the guy sings me these two jams I
bought a ticket I didn't even know what
I got myself into and I remember my
friend Joel Loya who went on to become
this this legendary tattoo artist and
music he did album covers for people
houses date in the scene - it was a
super artistic kid like but his brother
Josh Loya had a great surf career he was
this I remember when I was when I was
still living in Santa Cruz I would go to
Joel's house
his mom was like super cool like hippie
like you guys you guys want to smoke
weed you can like one of those kind of
parents and and his younger brother I
just remember I never really talked to
his younger brother but I
member he was always either in a wetsuit
or just getting out of it and I was like
well your brother surfs a lot and Joe's
like yeah he's pretty good and then he
ends up like for anyone listening right
now that's a surfer Josh he ended up
being this guy that competed all around
the world Josh Loya he was locked by
O'Neal like legendary guy but he was a
little kid back then that's so cool
so I go with that like growing up in a
beach community would that be like me my
friends going to play street hockey guys
well cameras coming on the water and
surf yeah I mean yes surfing is just
like yeah absolutely you know it would
be the same it's the same as surfing
it's just a part of the culture and a
part you know a part of your life like
growing up in Santa Cruz I didn't come
from a family like that I came from a
family you know my like my parents work
they weren't surfers but right I grew up
with people that surfing was just it was
no different than hey we're gonna go to
the park and and play baseball you know
or hey we're right we're gonna do so
cool yeah like hey you want to you know
like David it was you know their father
father son daughter would all surf
together and so and once again it's
funny because all those things like you
said a few minutes ago like like our
home and how the kids are coming here
tonight or just it was it's really
opposite of everything that like that I
was raised in the sense that like you
know my son and I served together my
daughter and I are going on a surf trip
to Cabo this summer it's really a part
of my life because those are all the
things that I you know I think
subconsciously I was like you know I
would see those families especially
after my family got divorced I would see
those families hanging out and I was
like damn dude I want to I want to load
up the truck and go surfing with my
family you know and in and then in those
type of things like I think stuck with
me so once I had a family I was like I
want to have the family that house you
know you don't think about it but then
all the sauce it kind of happens or
what's so cool about it is like to it
when stuff happens to outside of your
control especially when your kicks it
shapes the rest of your life but even
now as an adult you have choices to make
right absolutely because there are
people that will be like you know what I
never had this F the world on that and
they don't even and then they go down a
dark path man I've met people like that
done other people like you know what I
don't have this but I'm going to make
sure one day I will and I'm going to
provide that yeah
like I I'm one of my best friends
growing up his parents got divorced and
he pretty much grew up in our house and
he was like on his own man like ever
when he was like seven eight years old
he was a little latchkey kid so he was
by himself now he's the biggest family
man in the world
there you go he's Clark Griswold yeah
and I'm like dude your iShare on it I
love him so much you know it's funny I
totally that what I would say that has
that has a lot to do with what when you
said at the beginning and why do you
think you and Karen have stayed together
as long as you have and I would say
because when my parents got divorced it
was so much of a probably a letdown and
you know emotional probably something I
never really like dealt with now I was
like oh okay that sucks you know you
move on as a client you know you learn
how to survive uh and I yeah you know
you don't need our army yeah and also
you know and also you know there's
there's so many other things that happen
to kids and people and families that you
probably put in perspective and you're
like hey you know what I still got two
parents live in two different places and
they both love you like that dad to be
that cool to be like dude PACA back yeah
I'm here yeah yeah and my mom and my mom
super cool to it but the thing that the
thing that I reason I think I have the
family and I make fun of like yeah sure
it is like living backstage but you know
I remember going to Johnny Bonelli's
house and he had he had an older brother
an older sister another older sister and
him there was four and his mom and dad
and I remember I'd go there and I'd walk
in the front door and there was just
always something going man yeah that was
brother his brother was playing the
kinks at full volume it would make us
listen to them I get come on up here his
name is Steve get in here man yeah I
want to remember I can I remember I'm
sitting on this like just like shag
carpeting and he just had albums out and
he has a stereo and he's playing me the
kinks and old school stare yeah big
speakers huh and he and he's playing
that up front to us and he's like you
guys this is where it's at and we're
like well Steve's rat he's like a man
there he has AI Colonna ha ha ha
not shave and then I remember you go
down to another level because he was he
was living in the Attic and you got
another level and it's Donna and his
other sister Karen and they're like
they're like you know Donna's cool and
Karen's a little bit older than she's
like she's like maybe like we're
freshmen and she's like a junior senior
no hot problems going on some older
sister like oh ma then the hot girls
come over and they're like I'm gonna
wear the love I got they had they had
they had you know and then I remember we
ID dinner there and they would they
would say come on you know Joe God you
know I'd be standing out at Johnny's
house and he had the downstairs and I
remember they would they would have this
meal and they were all sitting around
the table and then and their dad and
them are all like they would like just
talking and busting on each other and
foods flying around like you know
passing it around due to me that's I'd
rather be in that environment and at the
Super Bowl backstage at a van Halen show
in 1984 I don't care family dinner
ball-breaking saw flying conversations
records dogs barking come to all the cat
peed on the sandwich yet we get that
sort of family chaos I think it's the
best allies and it doesn't exist that
much anymore it really does it does it
and in this city like to be able to XY I
first thing I said it was like all my
hair my arm stood up when I saw your
place and when I walked in and I felt
the love I want do to I'm in a home yeah
I still wanted to know people feel naked
man totally it's hard man you know it's
hard in the sense of it is hard to keep
the family unit together in the sense of
having dinner and and all sitting around
like that because nowadays you know
someone's got a tutor at this time and
so on so it's got some all pressure and
then you got you know I'm studying for
this or I got that and and I you know I
really try with the family we really try
to have and it's not even its it should
be every night but it's impossible but
we we have our dinner you know every
Sunday night or one night during the
week where we all sit down that's all
and it spend that time together because
it is it is important and but I also
understand you know the parents that can
because there's so many events if you're
trying to make oh my gosh just to keep a
roof over your head it's like I've seen
the American dream
crumble in my lifetime like dual incomes
people working two jobs for not as much
as what one person could make like I
remember talking to an old school comedy
store door guy who was here in the 70s
and he said from with a minimum-wage job
he would work at RadioShack during the
day and for extra money at the comedy
store at night he said minimum wage like
in 1977 whatever that was was enough
money for his own one-bedroom apartment
and a new car you know what you have
been wet cost of living oh my gosh it's
gone through the roof not even the roof
anymore I mean you'd be stoked if it had
just gone through the roof it's yeah
everything and then on top of it and the
fact that the fact that you can't just
have a job working at Radio Shack and
somewhere else and not make not be able
to live that the fact that that can't
even happen is oh my god you know it
it's that era and even the jobs you
remember when I was a kid just I
remember even coming to LA my first
apartment that I rented when I finally
moved to LA and 90 again 90 was 800
bucks for a two-bedroom off of sunset
Wow huge and I remember then going how
am I going to come up with the 400 bucks
for my half
yeah how much would that place be now oh
gosh I'm sure I'm sure that already 500
yeah 3,500 bucks stuff like that
you know it was right across street from
rock and roll rock and roll Ralph's and
rock and roll Danny
Wow so like around point etienne dude
Fuller fly you thought of that fuller
and Hollywood oh okay yeah then you have
7230 Ives oh yeah because you went up
the hill you were up behind Ralph's yeah
yeah Rocky Horror I call is it funny
that you drive I don't know and it's
actually called rock and roll route is
that on the side now this stuff I mean
that everyone called it rock and roll
like it like for the people like all I
can say is people that are listening is
it is imagine you just refer to
something as you know baseball 7-eleven
baseball you like or something right and
then all of a sudden the city because we
could everyone called it rock and roll
Ralph's is like I would say the
middle-class supermarket of the Greater
Los Angeles
and the fact that they actually changed
the sign to rock-and-roll raus I
remember I was like what but yeah that's
that's what that was my first place when
I moved and it's like right that's
musician central ah dude
I remember Aaron Burr and especially
then because like I when I when I moved
down here you know all I wanted to do
was was getting a band and and Alberti
when you moved here I was I was 23 I
just turned 23 so you've been in the
music scene for a little bit like if
you're trying to go to show us at
fifteen your Social Distortion
yeah first show first show was when I'm
15 and I never looked back I just it was
just shows I got in my first band um I
think Oh was that okay walk me through
that decision process Oh get into a band
yeah what made you want to do it and
where did the courage come from they do
it because I think that is fascinating
because I think everybody listening to
this there's something they want to do
yeah I mean for me for me man it for me
it was it was I was going to so many
shows and seeing so many bands and I
just really really nerded out on the
punk music scene that was happening and
I just felt I do you think you picked
punk over there with that Yahiro scene
there was a huge battle was great I got
I getting what you're great and talked
yeah give you talk to like like dean del
rey yeah like metal guy yeah he would he
can you know he was on that he I always
say like the punks were on one side of
the street and the metalheads were on
the other and it would you guys ever
meet in the middle all the time man back
then back then I remember I remember one
of the first times that like crucifix
played and in the crowd what people were
tripping out because there was there was
the guys they weren't even a big band
then it was just the guys from metalic
over there Wow we were like oh wow check
it out and like they were one of the
first bands that like that were
definitely Metallica gave a nod to like
crucifix and misfits and stuff like that
and Riveria day covers up yes it's um
one day they would go to the shows like
those guys so there was a lot of cross
back and forth and that was that was
super cool uh but for me too when I the
thing that got me to want to be in a
band has was I mean the thing that drew
me to punk rock was it's just what I
loved it was it's you know what it was
you know that whole that whole moment we
just had about the people at the table
and the KSR that's what punk rock gave
to me it was a sense of family and a
sense of belonging and I think I didn't
realize how much I wanted that and
needed that everybody long and also
wanting to be a part of something that I
felt at the time was really really
important you know like I was one of
those kids that like I remember like
sham 69 this band had the song like if
the kids are united they'll never be
divided
and like that song spoke to me the
band's I was in do seven seconds
they spoke about unity and about you
know being aware and being positive and
being alert bands like Minor Threat I
mean Minor Threat those bands spoke to
me youth Brigade they had these lyrics
that were about change and pause being a
positive individual and being an
individual into notes so looking for
yourself and then I really I really
latched onto that that's so thinking for
yourself there's just so much there
because it was almost like I remember
being afraid of punk kid like I was a
skateboarder kid and I was also like
first generation hip hop where I was
more of a city kid and I was like you
know what I don't want to go to hell my
big brother I was I would pray for my
big brother cause he would listen to
heavy metal I'm like if he listens to
another deal so I think God might not
just like turn his back on ya but in the
skate community you had everybody right
like all those little misfit kids and I
remember going well these kids they have
leather jackets I heard this one kid
carries a an eight ball sock and uses
that as a weapon that our two dudes
always got a blade with them like
dangerous I would say this man the the
scenes on the East Coast and the scenes
on the west coast at that point what
you're you talking late 80s Early 90s
yeah you know I would say there was
definitely there was definitely like the
East Coast the East Coast scene
definitely had those cruel they were
yeah there was that whole like skinhead
outcome
yeah so you know I I totally could
understand I mean I was dude I was I
remember the first group of punkers I
saw it wasn't so much like wow they're
gonna do something to me it was more
like I was just so tripping out the way
that they dressed and and I got a
statement right such a statement and it
was also such a such a what I loved the
feeling it caused with other people
around them like I loved like back and I
know it's hard to even imagine for
someone listening right now like like
the the feeling that say one individual
dressed a certain way could sit on a bus
or come into a restaurant or come into a
public setting and make a lot of people
feel uncomfortable interest and and I
was really drawn to that like and I
learned the power to it there was a
power to it and I loved that it like it
like it scared people like I laugh like
you know when you're sitting there and
it's silly now but like if you had
bleached blond hair spiky with eyeliner
an earring a bondage belt on creepers
peg Levi's and like you know a leather
jacket or a denim jacket and you're
sitting there with your skateboard
people would one or two things they
would either try to beat you up or be
just be so like what that like what is
that like why would you do that - yeah
and I got off on that I totally got off
on it 100% and and also I got off on it
because I think in my mind I thought
like I'm I'm I'm a part of this group of
kids and we're gonna change the world
man so we were like we're smart and
we're young and we're gonna our bands
are better and faster and louder and
we're going to make something out of
nothing and I was so into that there was
such a huge entrepreneurial spirit - I
was just you know I was you know one of
my best friends ended up you know he
ended up starting a record label out of
his bedroom that put on all these
records and then another note
true this girl that this this woman is I
remember this woman Denise bond man III
she took photographs of everyone and she
was this awesome photographer and then
yeah this definitely did bleed into
whole art team oh my gosh everywhere
everyone was doing something I remember
my buddies Korey O'Brien and Gavin
O'Brien there were these two brothers
and they they figured out how to talk
the dude at the veterans hall to rent it
to them and they brought Social
Distortion to San Jose they I was like
what they're like yeah we booked them
they're coming here to play we have to
sell tickets
we made a flyer you know I was like wow
and it was on Father's Day and my dad
was so like only I remember he was like
Joe only you would be going to a show on
Father's Day and he pulls around the
corner to drop me off it is packed and
he's like alright maybe I'm wrong you
know like what's up you know wow yeah
but like that's that whole the music
thing which which really mean that's
what I I think I was drawn to stand up
was I really feel that I mean there's
just so many similarities between just
straight up musician and comic and then
for me there's so much straight-up
relationship between punk rock and in
comedy you know and stand up and and you
could I could you the comparisons are
some of the shows feel like punk rock
like when you're at the meltdown and
you're doing a set you're like wow we're
in a basement slash kind of backroom
vibe yeah and you're like this is very
punk rock yeah and then sometimes when
you know I did a show it how would you
define punk rock how would I yeah I mean
punk rock in 2017 for me as as this is
my just personal feeling punk rock now
to me means it for me it's taken on the
definition of when everyone is doing one
thing and going in one direction and not
questioning ah they're just burnt and
you're tired and you're just want to get
through and alright whatever you just
follow along and they're all done it you
in line I'm not going to ask any
questions I'm not to add up a fight it
when you when you're able to step back
and go wait a minute hey I got asked a
question right now that's punk rock I
gotta find out why are we doing this why
why are we all going in that direction
why I got like the hour of your own well
shower very well and when you see um
people get get a negative response for
all just do it you know who cares come
on you're always asking too many
questions you know that to me is for me
and as adult man with the kids you know
and trying to think I know that's that's
the spirit of that episode about me
right now
young people you know people have asked
me what everybody thinks punk rock
musically you know like I mean you know
is punk rock you know I did it I was a
part of a festival called punk rock
bowling in Vegas this last weekend did
this you did this show they dig they do
that every year right every year a deal
big comedy show hard times presented all
the comics it was great yeah all those
bands playing there are these older I
mean every one of the bands are there
you know Iggy Pop ladies 70 years old
flashier is that music considered punk
rock yes it's the blueprint for it
yeah but punk rocks to me musically is
always the thing that is just so being
done for the only reason of I have to
make this music whether it's whether
it's hip hop with upgrade our electronic
ax whether yeah so it's obscure it's not
a sound it's not it really for me not a
sound that's a vile yeah if you were to
say Tilley about 70s punk rock okay we
can talk about the clash in the Ramones
all day long it'll be great but if you
weren't like what do you need a punk
rock music and spirit I'm like you know
music that that is being played for the
sole purpose where that artist is like
if I don't do this I can't breathe that
to me is punk rock now Ray Charles was
punk rock Frank Sinatra was punk rock
the beat I mean in spirit those bands
and any of the people I just mentioned
they were not supposed to have
it was not happening for them and they
they figured out a way to connect on a
bigger level and it happens so that's
what you know for me where I'm at my
life punk rock for me is definitely more
of an attitude and more you know it's
it's just it's something that I'm never
going to be able to shake it's just
always that that that moment of going
whoa why are we doing that
yeah even sometimes when I think that's
such a valuable question why just to ask
that you know yeah to be the guy to say
yeah I don't like that well what's so
interesting why don't you do it you're
part of this am I'm going back to you as
a kid as a teenager and if that like
that so many it's such an individual
thing right absolutely
but then also a teen thing it's so much
like stand-up comedy right like where
it's like this is my point of view but
yeah and the thing was stand up to the
thing that like I remember as a kid you
know seeing that first George Carlin
live from the Santa Monica Civic and
that record and a class clown it was and
that really phased me because that was
the first time I saw one guy just he's
standing on stage and like you know he
has no shirt on he has this denim vest
on these Levi's long hair I mean he's a
full-on hitting me you're like well
who's this dude and and then I put the
record on it might you know my parents
were super super like I said they were
in touch with with comedy and art and
music so I grew up in a household where
it where it was just always being like
you got to watch that live Joey hey come
in here and and listen to this this is
George Carlin this is Bill Cosby this is
okay dad you know hey listener I
remember my dad explaining to me what
dynamics meant and I was like I was a
kid and I came home with my band I'm
like dad check out my band I want you to
record it and he listens to you guys oh
my god
because I can't hear you I go yeah there
I am right there you know screaming over
the music he's like Joe you know there's
no dynamics to their music and I'm like
what do you mean dynamics and he goes
you know dynamics he's trying to explain
it to me he goes hold on and he goes
I'll never forget it he goes into the
living room is coming here and he puts
on a raycharles record and the song
starts out popping ah ba ba ba Bo and I
and then it goes breaks down and it's
just bass and drums and Ray and Ray
Charles are singing over the bass and
drums and prabha piano and then all of a
sudden it breaks up into the chorus and
the whole band kicks in with Ray and
then it breaks back down and my dad said
that's dynamics you bring it down
racing's see ray you can hear ray right
here Joe that's the dynamic it just went
down and then boom here comes the course
Joe everyone jumps in dynamics and I
remember that was a game-changer for a
while I was like I've never heard
anything explained to me that yeah so
because what it basically say is like
you need dynamics in it and like even
with stand-up you need dynamics you need
you need to you need those moments in
the bit where where where you know you
you you you you get the room really
really really quiet I do something to
that just naturally I don't even think
it's not a choice it just had those are
dynamics because elicitor you know I
remember I remember Eric Griffin said
something to me I was I was featuring
for heaven I love that - he's the best I
just watched him for the first time last
night on I'm dying up here oh and I'm
happy now yeah dude all I gotta say is I
was i enjoyed it and and Eric and Andrew
Santino who's in it is awesome two great
guys and you know al Madrigal I don't
know how I don't know cool I don't know
him
there's a bunch of comics involved with
it so I hope it runs for octave but uh
but the thing that what the thing that
Eric said to me was and this applies to
dynamics was was he he goes you know
weird I was featuring for him for a
whole weekend and you know one night
he's like he's like Joe you know dude
you gotta listen to the audience memo
what do you mean and I was like having
good sets he's like you know Aaron yeah
you don't listen Joey just steamroll or
you gotta listen and I and I remember
going you know okay and then about a
year later I was like oh I get what
you're talking about just because you
have the mic and you're talking doesn't
mean that you're not letting the dynamic
of this relationship with oh it's a
dialogue that's why I love stand up more
than that's my favorite thing that I
mean yeah so students the audience in
you man it goes back and forth energy
yeah and when there's
that volley you know it's just so great
and and he you know so like it for me it
just always been I just you know even
with my stand up and and the only thing
I can always go back to just because of
being apart and and having it in my life
for so long it's just that the vibe and
the kind of I'm able to understand
things better if I put them in a music
format like even stand up like you know
if I make a setlist for stand up I make
a setlist no different than I make a
setlist when I was in a band where I was
like okay we're gonna open with this I
want to do this do i you know it that
song in this song sounds similar what's
the better song okay and you know in
stand-up it's like alright i want open
with this I want I know I'm going to
close with this you know these two James
similar you know what I like this one
better or okay I know what I'm starting
with and I know it I'm ending with and
whatever happens here in the middle I
decline I've got these over here if I
want to go to them but let's also you
know let's also let the night in the
room and the crowd factor in because as
you know and once again it's like a jazz
because that's what jazz people talk a
hundred percent is it it's the moment on
stage of of material that happens
literally right there because of some
past that's where I write on a base or
the magic happens yeah that's it and I
just trust that like I want God bless
you thank you at the Comedy Store just
because of the the showcase environment
of the club or just about everybody's
only going to 15 minutes you might have
a monster show up into an hour in the
middle but generally the format is 15
minutes and the show starts at 9:00 and
it goes to two so if you're going up
three hours into a show can't really go
up with a game plan no you got to just
be in the moment with it and it's
awesome
it's just so much fun like I don't know
what I'm going to say 90% of the time
yeah a bit will come to me in that
moment but it's not you're having I
didn't have your you have your opening
bit no really yeah see I always have to
I know as soon as I touched the
microphone and words just come out I
allow it to just be yeah right I don't
know but now headlining a set and doing
an hour don't have a little more
structure yeah well because at that
point cuz was more responsible yet
rightly more DoD say listen the podcast
hey I got
record hey I want to come see you okay I
got to get Michelle um yeah I still even
if I'm doing it if I'm doing you know
the 15-minute set and whenever I always
like to at least because it's the
musician I mean I'm like I got it I have
to know where I got to have just even if
I'm don't say it I have to have it in my
mind of like it's like a sandwich I'm
like yeah the pieces of bread
well sometimes where I'm like I
definitely want to work on this [__]
tonight I sometimes have that and
sometimes I'm like I can't do it with
this crowd yeah it's not going to work
with this a lot of times a lot of times
I've always found to that like I'll go
with you like I'll go with an
expectation of like okay you know you're
going to be improv and you're like okay
cool yeah it's the eight o'clock show or
the ten o'clock show they're like okay
yeah you know you get your email okay
you're going to be on at this time and
then you get there and all of a sudden
someone drops in
and then I always love when something
happens it like I remember a while ago I
showed up and I was I was doing like 10
minutes and I have my little 10 minute
thing in Miami I'll do this do that
it'll be great Momo Momo Momo I'm going
up second it was perfect and then yeah
and then and then all of a sudden it was
one of those nights where was like
Daniel Tosh showed up you know so so
showed up day and showed up everyone
showed up and the guy that was running
the shows like I did you know I'm gonna
he's like feel bad but I'm gonna push
you back on track so then all of a
sudden all of those dudes show up and
then there was supposed to be one more
dude you know big name that was actually
the headliner yeah and then they go
we're going to put you up now so I go up
there with my ten minutes and then while
I'm up there uh you know I get the guys
looking at me and basically I you know I
could put two and two together oh so
they're saying stretch it out because
some shows know Wow
and what I loved about it was I'd
already done the ten minutes that I had
planned oh yeah I closed there's a big
red right around that time like where
I'm literally like hey this one thing
you guys like I'm gonna bail he's
basically saying like no dude like we
need you to stretch it out yes in those
moments you grow it's so much because I
literally was like oh wow it's like it
was like it's like it was like you had
sex yet you already had the orgasm
you're like oh this is great you had
your rhythm oh my god this guy
it goes through you're getting dressed
like no you gotta do we gotta start off
where you're like yeah how is that you
know and those to me are the the moments
that like those are those where her I
just I feel like that really trains you
and and works you yeah success doesn't
really teach anything right like it's
those challenges that it's awesome yeah
I love it like imma it's the coolest
thing about comedy that said it's always
going to keep me humble yeah yeah well
you know like they just said that last
doc you know it's like Peter said you
know it doesn't matter who you are
you're never ever not susceptible to a
bad night oh yeah
yeah you know and then I don't and I
don't know if that's like if that
applies you know the other types of
professions because even with bands you
can have a bad night but a lot of times
I mean I don't know how many times like
I would do show and we get done and I
was like dude we killed it and then you
talked to the bass players like ah dude
I was having a bad night like really I
didn't notice Yeah right or like you
know you are you think the band the
guitar player after the show they're all
dude we are killing it bass player
drummer was high-fiving and then you're
the singer you're like god I just didn't
feel like I ever dropped in well you
know what I think it is that and you
didn't get through it and the crowd
doesn't know this is what I love about
stand up like you could in just about
everything else I can think of that's a
live form of entertainment
the audience can enhance it make it
better but it doesn't influence it
directly like with stand-up um and I
know a lot of people disagree with this
but not just my opinion I am it's almost
like acting and the audience is your
scene partner if you put Robert De Niro
with a community theater person it's not
going to be a great scene De Niro is
going to be like you're not giving me
what I need to kill this it's the same
thing with an audience there are times
where it's like it's just a bad night
and I because I've seen every comic
bat-bomb everybody and there are times
where a great audience can elevate a
mediocre performer and you can ride that
energy and it's glorious and wonderful
but it's like if you're in a band
you could play in anger garage man you
don't need and I'm shorting out makes
him law I always say inflowing I would
say that is that is it I mean the first
thing you said I totally agree with 100%
and I and I for years well I thought
forever like no no it's always it's
always on you it's never on the audience
and now that I'll say straight up that's
[__] because I I know for a fact you
you can walk into a room and if there's
just a bad energy that night people were
battling traffic the front row you can
feel okay something's going on with that
couple they are fighting like that and
they fought the whole way here ok that
guy right there and this person they're
they're not even paying attention
this and you've made me so much more
into it I can pick up on guys yeah oh
where you're like oh this guy's having a
great time hopefully his energy will
spread to this garrison me I'll say it
though the other night I was the other
night I was doing a set and everyone is
having the best time and then I'm always
the personnel focused on the one person
they ain't buying it yeah and I always
it's like I said this this this one this
one woman was upfront and everyone
around her is having the best time and
and I go man you're not feeling it are
you and I just looked at me and I go no
I go no it's ok so ok I'm gonna I'm
telling you right now I'm so stoked
everyone else have a good time friend
but because of the way my brain works
I'm going to work even harder right now
for you to laugh like when you truly
laugh at some point and if you know I
respect that short I'm going to get you
at a certain point and then they're out
there laughing and then I said something
to the effect of like you know you know
you chose to be here like you can leave
right we're not at DAV Yap you don't
have to rejoice manage you start up
everything in life is choice yeah and
then you find out you find out you know
half the time that like oh it's because
blah blah blah you know oh yeah
sometimes it's somebody doesn't speak
English all day on it right and yes I
feel like such a dick that's why I like
I don't and I never know I'm like
everybody's on their own journey I've
told audiences sometimes like I just
have joy in my heart and I'm just trying
to put it into her I saw a comic would
say hey buddy I'm over here and then he
kept saying is why because she's blind
yeah
you're like yeah yeah okay you never
know is I feel like I'm the dick oh yeah
I didn't say that but but uh but the
thing though that uh and it's funny
because with music I always tell people
are like you know with stand-up you need
an audience and you down at two people
three people you're fine there are
people to get a vibe but with a band
week you and I could start a band and I
could be sending you songs and you
sending me and then we practice our own
and then we show up for sound check we
run them they sound good we play that
night and crush yep but you can't do
that with stand-up now you have to have
that it's like it's had to have been
going on since back in the day before
fire was discovered they had a guy burns
his hand and everyone laughs yep and and
they're like wow that was like that
emotion we just do that again
now yeah throw the rocket that other guy
I always you know say the first stand-up
comic was the guy that didn't kill
anything in the hunt so he's just
telling the story about and then as he's
making every left he starts taking food
off their place yeah I like you know
what I mean like so then the Tigers go
on this way you saw what happened yeah
anyway yeah yeah it starts and also
given shout outs to the dudes that did
yeah
Larry I go and that's that's like that's
like that's him just making sure
everyone's like oh yeah man when Bill
killed the dinosaur I mean I don't know
if they're still but like yeah yeah when
you call man when you cut the tiger that
was so awesome because I oh man I ran
did you see me run and I was scared you
know I was scared you were yeah that's
that Oh funny yeah so alright because I
think this would be a cool way to bring
it all together like you're starting to
go to shows and at some point you know I
want to do that because you did that
twice so many times in your life right
like where you're like I want to be in a
band yeah and you did it yeah like I
want to be a family man and you did it I
want to start a business and you did it
you know I want to be a comic and you
did it yeah take that for what take any
of those little variables and go okay
there's now I see something it's
creating a desire in me how do you face
the fear to take your dream and make
that a reality
um you know I don't know if there's ever
like whatever it is that I've ever
gotten
you I just I just have that moment where
I dig it and I'm like wow I you know
that would be cool and then I run a
million scenarios in my head like all
those things you just described like you
know being in a band or we're starting
you know side one dummy or being a
parent or getting into stand-up comedy
and going yeah I want to do those things
yeah they were all there were all things
that I I would say those were all things
that I always you know toyed with and
liked those ideas maybe not in in the in
the sense of like did I always want to
start a record company and put out
records did I ever think you know I
would own a record company for 23 years
and and put out those records from these
bands that that are so influential
people love like I never thought that
but was I putting on a talent show when
I was in seven or eight years old and
cleaned out a garage and did magic at it
and then had a kid tap dance and they
had another kid in that mic yeah I was
fooling any kid I was so into matter how
many performers start with the magic I
was a full magic kit I've been done
magic was that like so so if you look at
that little that little the the little
scenario I gave you clean out the garage
gonna do is shown it so there's the
promoter and lash business gal there so
that's cruising around but he also wants
to entertain on I do so he's like going
to do magic so there's the there's the
band and and up comic giving and
receiving love that's all performing and
I got to do that and then putting other
people on the show is probably like the
manager like I had your pretty rad at
drugs he convinced other kids to be a
part of your show um because my dad said
to me a long time ago when I was I
remember it was when I was starting side
one dummy and I was like oh gosh how
will I make this work and everything and
he you know he was on the front lines
all through high school and he said to
me he goes Joe you have a gift and I'm
like what do you mean because you have
the gift
to get people to do things that they
might not normally do I was like what do
you mean he's like not misusing it like
getting people like taking advantage of
people you don't right like I don't see
that because now you have the ability to
talk people into doing things they might
not normally do and at that time it was
probably dude Steve it'd be so rad if we
got an imported dad's car yeah yeah your
mom dude your dad what dude he said to
you anytime you want to go to the city I
don't know Joe dude dude he'll be stoked
right now doo doo doo to check it out
all hang out here I'll talk to your mom
you'll get get your dad dude just say to
him hey man dad I was wondering and let
him know you know I've learned how to
drive I think it's time I take my own
you know I be that I need back yeah and
you'd be like yeah you're right maybe I
can troll sales maybe I should drive all
seven of us to the city in San Francisco
and and everyone will give me gas money
yeah and it'll be rad and that so that's
what he meant by that and that's just
later on turned into hey man you should
make a record and we should put it out
why because we are going to live and
breathe your band we will do everything
we can to meet you know to make it
happen for you and I think when people
you know so that that combination right
there that would be that business part
of it yeah and then and then the
performer thing it never ever left
because from the moment I wasn't like a
little kid I loved performing whether it
was a whether it was you know at those
dinners that we talked about earlier or
whether it was doing magic at arts pizza
on 41st Avenue it for free slices for my
family um doing that and then that
turned into what we talked about the
music and I first went as a fan and the
other thing is this you know as much as
like people might be listening like wow
man like this guy has done a lot of [__]
you know we'll keep in mind like hey I'm
50 years old yeah like for everyone
listening I'm and you love me 27 I know
I never did drugs um but so don't do
drugs and you'll look good um uh it was
funny when I was at the punk rock
balling thing the I always people are
like I'm 30 these comics I'm 35 and I
had up there I'm like
guys I'm 50 now I'll tell you right now
all of you look like [__]
pump the brakes a little bit yeah put on
some lotion you gotta wear the start
doing zoom exercise drink water like we
don't pump the brakes first of all
you're in Vegas try to make it back uh
but but it was funny but the thing that
going back to this like the people
someone listening right now it you know
it here's the deal I'm 50 and I've had
an amazing run and all these things that
we just talked about whether it's the
the music the comedy the singing in the
bands the touring the all this has been
amazing but I will tell you that I was a
kid that was into the Bee Gees and magic
and I thought YMCA Village People what I
thought Abba was cool I liked
rollerskating
I wasn't like I thought like I was when
people say like oh so you're a nerd I'm
like no I was cool but I didn't realize
those weren't probably cool thing you
know say it's like that but I like it
wasn't like I rolled into this family
where my dad was this ripping musician
and my mom wracked like I'm saying like
if if it's possible for me with like I'm
saying this I have I'd say my life is
this my life if you put it in percentage
and this is just me being this isn't
comic being like things like in you know
the typical oh I'm gonna bag on myself
what's that well when you
self-deprecation it's the first thing
you do as a comic friend everyone check
out how big my [__] nose is and I
write write write ha you get laughs like
oh if I bag of mice yeah okay it's cool
and it's also not genuine yeah but but
being you know this is a being
self-deprecating I'm just saying this is
my this is this is why anyone that's
listening right now you you can you
could [__] get so rad right now
because I my life has been based on 35
to 40 percent talent and then I swear -
it's either 60 or 70% work ethic effort
sometimes dude it's been 80% work ethic
20% down I
I heard Dean delray interview Krystal
Leah's dad once on a podcast yeah it was
awesome because Chris's dad is like this
amazing director
they live up above us get out of here
I'm not in this neighborhood but they
live in the next neighborhood the La
Crescenta area - that's fantastic I am
her just a really quick armor I remember
I listen to I mean I love Chris Wright
that he's best and he's been super cool
but when I remember I listen to him on
WTF podcast with mayor and I didn't hear
now yeah with Krista Lee and it was
great and then at one point Chris is
like yeah you know sometimes like Marin
was saying to him like yeah you know you
ever out now and people you know try to
hit you up you know you think yeah it
it's kind of weird because someone will
say this or that but whatever and he
goes you know the conversation really no
goes nowhere and and then I remembered
the first time I met him right when he
was saying that and all I could say to
Daliya was yeah he's like him sup you
know he talks he's kind of his head he's
like a seven and I go dude
he goes yeah what's up and I go can't
even [__] it I live in Glendale and he's
all yeah
and I argue for Lux Vegas yeah all right
cool and I swear to God
sir I swear to God when he was saying so
most people talk total I was like he's
talking about using my conversational
area so anyway what did Chris D'Elia
static he said that a talent doesn't
really matter until you're already
established essentially he was like it's
all about persistence I he was like
persistence and work work or work until
somebody finally says yes and then you
know what he was like the toughest
things getting your first gig and he
goes but the next toughest thing is your
next one because then it's persistence
person it's all persistence and then a
little bit of talent and good some once
you're in then your talent can take you
and sustain you to the next level but
it's a talent doesn't even matter
without persistence and work ethic
that's what I took from it and I
completely agree
I totally agree I mean I mean we're
sitting here in you know you walked into
living proof of that
you know you met you know my kids you
said to them I yeah yeah we're sitting
we're
sitting in you know in it you know in a
room that has been built and paid for by
persistent it's not talent like I I wish
I could tell you that it was but then I
don't because now now that I'm on the
other side of it I love working like I
like to me work I get up in the morning
I love to work there say I love the
fresh pot of coffee a blank piece of
paper what can I do
I mean today I do is all blessing I'd
Ruggles yeah alright so it's all like I
think we're dangerously getting to the
point where we're going to start robbing
people of the joy of the struggle how
about like going yeah
how much failure took me forever to
realize that that's there is no failure
it's just learning you're just learning
another way now that word for the
experience is the wrong word and like
the wrong word unlike now like I
listened to Rogen's podcasts all the
time and he talks about like it's so
good to suck because you're learning so
much you're learning how to get good
absolutely and then when it does when it
does pan out and you are good that it
feels so good because you've created
that yeah and then there's those
transferable skills right like I did I
had a conversation about it a while ago
he was in his band he's actually there
they're playing their last show tonight
for the school it was at this they were
like there's a party going on and a
bands doing a show to my dude my son
driving my son to his band show and then
my daughter's having the party and and
yeah I'm doing out over driver that
doesn't get paid it's like yeah but the
thing that my son had he had this moment
where he played this show before the
show you know I you know my wife's like
hey aren't you gonna tell him that maybe
do this I go no III we talked he didn't
talk to the sound man he didn't hang
with his band they were all running
around playing tag and you know hey
they're 12 years old but this is show
her clothes in bro so you you know and
Karen's like are you going to say
anything I go no and we were there
places packed they went up and they blew
they sucked he found out lyrics eptas
sawed the guitar player was too loud the
backups were terrible drummer started
wrong they were they were all talking
amongst each other and we get in the car
that night
and we jump in the car we're driving
back to Glendale Ana you know it's just
me and him and it's that silence and I
you know I'm like alright
I have his moment you know like you know
we only we both know what just happened
yeah we're not gonna ignore you don't
yeah and then he goes so what do you
think about tonight and I go what did I
think about tonight I would you think
well you know Bubba Bubba excuse excuse
excuse this that well you know that I go
yeah he goes we keep driving say
anything he goes but what it what did
you think and I you want me to tell you
what I really find was yeah I think it
sucked I think you guys suck and he just
goes what and he looks at me and he goes
I can't believe you'd say that like what
kind of dad tells their son that their
band sucks I go me bro because the band
is sucks I go you forget
dude you're playing van Halen you forget
the lyrics you're in Pasadena bro
you cannot that's like I go do do you
know that the dudes in that band drove
past the street where you played
probably tonight I go bro you don't go
to the sound man you didn't talk to him
about hey so-and-so is going to sing
backups your guitar player is way too
loud because you never did a soundcheck
yeah never you know he's sitting on he's
looking at me I go hey if you want me to
tell you that it's great bro like I did
when you were you know seven and eight
then that's cool but if you you know
you're telling me you really want to do
this and you want to play music and I'm
not going to I'm not going to pacify you
anymore man or almost 13 and he just
looked at me and he had his moments and
and then you know as in in parenting you
you let you like throw it out there then
you let it like you got to let it's like
those type of conversations have to
marinate you know in your kids has to
marinade you're like okay and then it's
one of those things were like three days
later on the way to school yeah hey Dad
we got a show and you know I talked to I
talked to Joe or he's turning his you
know we talked about the whole guitar
thing and from now on I'm gonna start
the song I'm going to go up there I'm
going to introduce the band and then
that gives them time to check out you
know I'm like okay cool so then fast
forward a month later they have the same
gig yeah and they're there and dude I
walk up on the show and all four dudes
are sitting out in front in line ready
to go ready to go just like a comic
right before you're like not like not
running around at the body
why can't they work dude they're in the
know they got up there and they played
and then and then they got done and they
were driving home it was like a replay
of a month earlier and he's like what do
you think and I go what I think I go I
think you guys [__] killed cause you
did so so awesome yeah again you got up
there no [__] around
you guys knew you had to bring it you
had your lyrics wire you had the guitar
where was supposed to be you look good
you guys were a unit you were in he's
like you know he was you know he's like
into it but the the idea of everything's
epic you know all the time I mean we
live in a society where everything is
just got to be awesome all the time and
it's not man and and what I would I feel
like whether it's stand-up or being in
the band is it what you just said and
what you whether it was on Rogen's
progress or crystally is dad it is so
true and if there's a secret in this
town is it it's really about it's just
deliver on what you say you're gonna do
that is my secret to success I just if
if someone gave me a job I didn't make
excuses I got it done and now there's a
lot of opportunity and it's accepted to
make excuses hey man I need that by
11:00 I know but they got stuck in this
and then this is happening okay okay
cool well you know who Jocko Eliquis
chaco will is that the like the guy that
hosts the like Navy SEAL yeah guys do
armed extreme ownership guy that's his
whole philosophy yeah he has a great TED
talk about I gotta check it out war
going sideways yeah
and taking full responsibility yeah I
mean I
there's I learn it's so interesting like
how you could have warriors on one side
and like chubby sidekick comedian and
I'm learning so much on how to be a
better comedian by studying Navy SEALs
absolutely not I mean like there's these
transferable skills to life it's
fascinating I think it's all about
because I really think it's all about
it's all about applying those those
ideas thoughts and philosophies to
whatever it is you're doing like I'm
like there could be people listening
right now that are like yeah hey man
check it out comedy's not my thing but I
really really want to open up a coffee a
coffee shop like I've always wanted yet
or I've always what I want I have an
idea for a pizza parlor or answer place
and this is why I think it could be and
I'm telling you all those things that we
that are a part of success whether it's
a band whether it's a comedian whether
it's a business whether it's a marriage
rather it's a friendship it's all about
work ethic and deliver effort in and
delivering on what you say you're gonna
do
I am number one key to success someone
asked my partner and I that I remember
when our company turned 20 years old
what's your key to success you know and
they wanted this answer of like well you
know when we look for bands you know
yeah you don't say this right now the
key to success is just falling through
on what you promise someone that is the
key to success and also what I've
learned as I've gotten older is not
being afraid to say Steve dude as much
as I want to be getting better at the
time doing it say and then now yeah got
it and I got to get better at it and
better at it and making boundaries so
when I do say yes happen and also when
you say yes you are giving that person
the all of Steve yeah
giving them the bats the other thing two
guys I want to just give that's just my
nature so I just want to but the problem
is if I give away too much then nobody
gets what they deserve and also if you
start giving away too much that you you
know you start if you start like if
someone says to you hey man you're like
a lot of times people hit me up and
they'll say hey I wanna do an interview
with you I go okay and I'll do I do I'll
do an interview with the kid that has
the fanzine out of that local high
school thing - all the way - anything in
between I'll do it but the one thing
that I always get a little bummed on is
when someone says hey man I want to do
an interview with you and they send me
the questions and then I got to write it
all out and I'm like dude I'm gonna let
me do your homework yeah I'm doing I'm
doing their work here and and what ends
up happening those I understand a lot of
times those type of interviews actually
turn out to be cool because someone's
like hey check it out it's running I do
have complete control over how what you
say but the thing that answering your
question if I say yes to those
while I'm typing it I'm resenting the
dude or the the pressure such a great
barometer that's where it's on measures
anger coming into play it's like givin
away - I shouldn't have said it not on
them it's on me as always I forget I
think it was that producer guy they did
the documentary the kid stays in the
picture Robert I learned that uh Robert
Evans right Robert Evers right where he
goes I look back in the things I regret
or when I said yes and I really meant
you know and it's like I get it now now
that's one of the best movies okay let's
go and now all done with photographs
there's no moving actors in that so cool
yeah it's all like news and yeah it's
amazing
are you a Broadway Danny Rose fan one of
my all-time favorite movies that might
be my favorite Woody Allen every
Thanksgiving I watch that's a move our
smiles on okay so good I don't see it be
it they cut the put out of the beard
yeah yeah I love what they say
when he says I don't see you just making
these you know in joints I see colleges
University yeah that's so great ah gee
ah Michael ah I'm so good so good my son
and I put that movie on on Sunday just
because we want to hear those people in
the background and like pretend same
thing with same thing with it's like
inviting company over it safely with
Robert it's like with moodstruck you
know I've never seen my god are you
serious yeah dude you you have to watch
that alright I could do it oh my it's
the best it'll put you in the best movie
it cher she's beautiful and awesome and
then of course Nicolas Cage when he's
still Nicolas Cage you know I lost my
hand it's like oh my god Soviet it's
Danny Aiello and that I don't know which
one did okay I mean I proxy might be I
yeah and then and then the music in it
dude the music Vikki cars in it old
school how many of you do we just lose
that are listening right now you're on
your you're on your run or you're in
traffic and you're just like what are
they did it's not the coolest thing
about podcasts who knows who's listening
yeah and where they're listening that's
fascinating and it's so cool and I love
it podcasting just in general as a tool
to bring people together well I love I
mean I was super super psyched when you
asked
because I remember when you came over
when your record came out yeah I played
you the a bit off of the record the
MacDonalds bit and I remember what did
your kids think of that by the way that
they're in your act
oh they they've been our act from the
beginning band they're cool with us yeah
they're totally cooled it yeah they're I
mean I think you know it was funny
because that when the record came out I
came out on April 28th and I did I went
out on the road
all the last two weeks of April so I was
like I was everywhere are the it was
whenever the amount of records could
start scanning you know okay the cell
you actually have real tangible records
yeah why was cell hours on the road and
it was crazy because the record you know
the record came in number one standard
record on billboard because the first
two records were music records so mine
was number three and it came in and then
and they said yeah well it's the number
one stand record so it was incredible it
was a great journey it was amazing
um the thing that was fun though was um
when I had my I headlined at The Improv
here in Hollywood and in honor it was so
yeah you know and I'm such a nerd when
it comes to all that stuff like I I
still like you know when I get a gig on
a Friday or Saturday night and you go
down there and you just think of the
history of those those those clubs and
the people I just yeah I really now
especially at this point in my life I am
so much I'm so grateful and like I make
sure like they don't drink before I go
onstage so like I'm really able to
really like remember and drop in to the
moment of like wow like in my opinion I
think stand-up is the greatest drug
there is yeah and anything else just
gets in the way yeah I don't want to
drink I'm doing nothing it's like that
connection with other human beings it
was magic yeah I love a drink afterwards
though if I had a good set I love it I
love to depart to have a nice drink but
the thing that was great was this one
show you know my family you know they
don't come out the shows because you
didn't show us all time but um they all
came to the night of the release like so
the record came out on Friday April 28th
and then I a headline that just don't
always just smash it's so great they
were all there and it was even crazier
as they brought their friends so my son
had his whole crew of his friends and
then my daughter had her friends and
then you know my wife had some friends
and there was always people there and
they were
you know there they had I gave them
tables in the back of the room because I
know that they don't want it but it was
such a great feeling after the show and
you know my son goes with me on the road
I brought him up to San Francisco at
Cobbs when I was with Maz Jobrani loves
Nate this is like yeah I think Maz
wanted Nate to hang around more than me
when they came to the first night but
then he hung out with my dad the next
two you know and he's like where's Nate
no he's not gonna come every night why
not you know as he loved him but you
know like when I went with Eric Griffin
I'll bring Nate but so my son's around
it enough so cool but it was great that
night because when I got done with the
show and we're on that ride back home
you know cuz we hung out afterwards and
then we were all driving back to the
house he goes yeah dad you did good
tonight like he you know he knows when
it's good which it's like me saying
because I'll say the same thing what you
think and yeah he'll say to me straight
up I don't know no not too many laughs I
don't know that bits not working I
remember I bombed in front of him once
with mods in San Francisco I bombed so
hard dude first time I ever felt Matta
the flop sweat yeah that was a myth I'm
like oh ooh oh no it's really I remember
you know when I knew the flop sweat had
kicked in is it called San Francisco I'm
featuring for Mont or I'm opening for
Moz and I'm getting a comedy show it's
one of the toughest things doesn't tell
me that the audience you know a lot of
the audience doesn't speak English so
you know they're not going to get your
references to a lot of the stuff you
know I didn't put two and two together I
go up there do my son just end dude it's
it's cops the place holds like a
thousand people shoot it's packed my son
is sitting in a table in the dark but
off to the side you know but like up
front we're like I can see them I'm
going through the set and then my head
I'm like what is going on like these
bits usually work like and all of a
sudden I remember I start sweating and
you'll laugh I go damn dude
I remember it being this hot up here
last time like and I'm like am I out I
go oh [__] this is floc sweat like a
sweat it like like like maybe a pregnant
woman guess or a woman in menopause do
like I and I remember I get done and as
I'm walking offstage and the next guys
coming up it's like
kind of quiet and my son says because I
walk out while the comics took on so
there's this moment where like I get to
my son quick enough before the next guy
grabs the the host grabs the mic yeah
and my son says loud enough Oh dad that
was terrible
I know crowd goes nuts they start
laughing and I I'm like oh man and you
know he's like oh you know we walked
backstage and then this is the best part
I go upstairs and Maz and I are sitting
there like damn dude that was rough he
goes ah Joe man you know what dude I
gotta tell you you gotta you know bail
this bail that he goes give me your set
and he goes what do you got he goes you
know that joke about the threesome put
that at the front you know that stuff
you do about your eyebrows dude bring
that you know buh-buh-buh-buh take
though he goes all the other stuff with
the parenting that these people are not
getting out there they're like yeah why
would the why would you coach your son's
baseball team you know like they're
they're not going to get it it's a the
culture difference it's not there I go
my son and I are is one of the best
moments ever my son's there and we're
ending between first show seconds and
we're writing [__] out a moving he's
like no no moves out there is it which
is crazy because I'm like should I do
the threesome joke at the top he's like
do it while we were all it's like yeah
exactly
and I go back to out second show and and
I go back outside showing it at work and
we got the laughs and then I come
backstage and my son's there and he
gives me a big hug and Maz is like dude
and he was like he was I think Maz was
just stoked like it was funny because
Maz was like one of the few comedians
that actually I mean dude he's
headlining he doesn't need to spend
spend time with sunny going over a joint
man is out yeah it was just like that
was the thing and then and then it was
it was great to fix that with my son and
it's great lessons for your son about
yeah gotta make adjustments man there
you go bro you know it was I I made his
mistake man I went up there I went up
there without you know looking at the
audience seeing what kind of eyes the
last time I did not like the last time I
ate it was because it was just a
scheduling thing but it's like I know
for me part of this thing I have to do
is I have to be in that room and feel
that or otally I have to feel the room
and get adjusted to their energy and
like I guess I'm making subconscious
reads but it's like if I if I park my
car and run up on stage I don't
have an act man yeah I don't have like
jokes so I have to connect or or do
poorly I totally I totally 100% philia
and agree you got I feel it it's like
it's like anything else man before you
go for a run you stretch out before I go
for a surf I stretch out before I skate
I stretch out yeah you know I I you you
get in the mode you feel the room I I
will though like if I'm in a room and
someone's crushing and I'm going up next
I do now don't feel a like a
responsibility I got to hang out in that
room I'll walk out and I'll be like hey
you know what okay I got a feel for
what's going on in there yeah cool and I
go outside and I love to just be like I
like I don't want to hear I just want to
like go okay what when I get up there I
it's going to be reset that's all yeah
bank accounts zero zero I got to fill it
up with laughs and they'll trust me yeah
that's my whole analogy for sure yeah
for sure for sure what would tonight
like you record when you recorded the
album it was it was you know Louis you
know you know the Bible are played great
it's just a the people the people to go
to the lawyer Comedy Store they're there
for a good time they they know the
history of the clubs so they know it can
go in any direction yeah and the room is
just it's built where the only thing
people can focus on even if they're not
into you is on you it yeah built so and
the history of the room is great and
once again vibes you can feel an energy
in that room when you come in right and
I love it down there I love it
me too I love it what's the name your
album name the album is Josip nowhere
near the top and it's on red vinyl and
what I was going to say if it's cool
with you yeah hey if you're listening
and you've enjoyed this rant that Steve
and I have had together which was I can
still can't thank you enough for having
me this is I could hang out with you
always
that's whenever you want to hang out I
love meeting awesome you know yo it's a
bummer is that I remember do you
remember who introduced us now oh uh uh
the Laugh Factory yeah iliza shlesinger
oh my yeah yeah I'm one of the first
comics I met and you were super cool and
then remember we got together and we
just talked about writing we went had
coffee I'll do it any time I'm like
really yeah
and you were like yeah let's do it that
was like almost seven years ago time fly
yeah but hey if anyone wants I was going
to say the records on red vinyl
and I we made like 500 of them and they
gave me like another there's like I
think graph like 100 left and what I
love to do is if you want and you email
me right now just Joseph Jo ESI be the
number 2 2 at gmail.com send me an email
and then on out of people to send an
email from this I will pick a winner and
send you a copy of the record so oh
that's so cool I always like to do that
and then for the people that don't win
I'll send you an email and then when I
come through town I'll get you in for
free
that's Kim show that is so awesome there
you go dude I love you buddy thank you
all right now thank you so much I get
this more this is good family
oh joy
[Music]
my buddy Joe school be sure to check out
his new comedy album it's called nowhere
near the top and it's on Amazon iTunes
and he actually has some physical
pressings I was lucky enough to get an
actual record record which is the
coolest ahh Leah feels we're talking on
the phone my favorite part of the
podcast every week is our gratitude list
and it's just fun to hang out with you
and into your face light up what do you
think of something but I'll start it go
for it I'm so grateful this week
my buddy onyx there's nothing like I've
talked on the podcast before I got one
of my favorite things in life is
unexpected doughnuts oh and walk into a
room and there's just doughnuts there
that's my favorite unexpected unexpected
visitor this week my body was traveling
the world it was like hey man I'm gonna
be coming through LA he said alright if
I crash for a little bit and I was like
why don't return me to a week and my
buddy Corey's been hanging out all week
it's so much fun
and yesterday we went we got a million
different kinds of ice cream that I'm
gonna be able to get to share with the
guys when they come over today and
really is great oh I'm just proud of you
that you're sharing sometimes I get good
stuff like that I'm gonna give stuff for
my friends but this is the stuff they
can't get all the good stuff I'm
grateful I'm grateful for like Skype and
even I was just thinking my dad used to
do the one video chat first came out he
would do with my grandma on something
called like see you see me or I see
someone like that it's not like when the
waybig get like I've dial-up so even
though it were on the phone I was just
thinking like oh yeah we like FaceTime
exist and Skype so now like you can see
the people - awesome it really is
awesome
oh I'm grateful I got a text today from
Ryan from Don Carlos
oh cool how do we do an answer of the
show he's doing awesome
but I'm definitely grateful for his food
and then I went to Domingo to sweep the
other on official sponsor Emily they had
like 10 people working behind the
counter no she's on fire right now
pants Ligon they're gonna have to take
over like that entire block which I'd be
totally okay right no oh good hopefully
there's absolutely so good I'll be
grateful when Domingo's extends the
hours past 6:00
you that of you extremely good that's
perfect
oh I got another one I'm so grateful for
pool whether I want to go outside and
swim in the pool it's perfect today
summer and I'm grateful that even though
even when it's a hundred degrees here
that there's not really any humidity the
humidity kills all because you can oh
yeah you can be in jeans here in 100
degrees and you're not gonna die that's
such a good point
oh you know what I'm grateful for I was
in the supermarket yesterday normally I
do my grocery shopping late at night
like on my way home from the comedy
store right so it was just so great
could be in there during prime hours
it's just it reminded me so much of my
comedy on because I saw so many moms
with little kids running around crazy
like mom what could they have for me
look they have like little kids
negotiating purchases and it made me
laugh so hard
but then like I went down this like the
cereal aisle cuz I I don't really go
down the junk food aisles unless it's
cheat day there's so many delicious
options you know they make a Captain
Crunch doughnut cereal it's a little
mini doughnuts Captain Crunch style and
then you know how like I had that joke
like if you haven't been done the ice
cream aisle since you were a kid there's
flavors
now that Willy Wonka couldn't think of
only I hadn't been down the ice cream
Island a couple months there's so many
different types of frozen treats it's
absolutely amazing it's the golden era
of fat kid joy have you is there
anything that you couldn't find forever
I from the time I was a kid I liked
chocolate eclair bars they always have
the Strawberry Shortcake ones but they
never have they had one but a Claire bar
I know they just go to town in Sherman
Oaks you have everything I mean
everything things I couldn't even
imagine oh and it's like I have
everything you can get Carvel ice cream
cakes you can get a cheesecake factory
cheesecake you could get ice cream made
with hostess Twinkie you can get
everything now I almost felt like I got
it was it was I felt like Charlie Bucket
touring the wonka factory amazing and
you could get you could get all of them
I'm trying so many delicious options I
like I want and I don't even get them
that much but I
like those like little tiny Pines so you
don't have to get a whole pint of ice
cream yes yes because in that way if it
would like I what I love about order and
Chinese food is that everybody shares a
little bit you can exploit almost like
getting up off a delivered to your house
to get a little tiny pint its you can
you get the flavor it's all about the
delicious options right it's all it's
all about oh now I just know in full
this a spoonful that it's the absolute
best now I want like a hot fudge sundae
though that's all I can promise right
now so delicious I'm no good I just want
all the all the people out there to be
if you'll do a gratitude list can you
can people be grateful that they grew up
in a town that allowed ice cream trucks
I'm still mad at my town no ice cream
fry now my town every once in a while we
that have a guy break the law if they
weren't allowed to do it she was a rogue
I agree me I he was like I'm gonna bring
so I'm gonna break through this barrier
and bring some joy some chubby little
kids at the baseball field Oh ice cream
truck is one of the greatest experiences
in life I love it Lilian
oh you know what I'm grateful for what
I'm going to be working again on our TV
show this summer so I'm so it's like
going back to summer camp I'm so
grateful that I'm going to see my buddy
sets and Matthew and Dan and then I
think there's new kids coming to campus
you you're gonna have to haze where
there's more people to hang out with now
I don't I don't ever hate anybody
because I never want them to age me
that's a good that's a good theory I
always I always joined in on the hazing
cuz I went through what everyone has to
go through now I'm the exact opposite
I'm like I never I would never want
anybody to go through it that's why I'm
so nice to the new kids at joke at the
Comedy Store
oh yeah yeah they get beat down
someone's yeah I'm like hair I'm not
gonna make it worse I know I know how
bad it is
oh you're the nice guy Steve everyone
else thinks it's like aw I need to I
need to make someone else feel what I
went through but ten times worse I don't
know I can't do that to people
I wanted to the exact opposite I'm
grateful there are people like you Steve
let's ungrateful
you know it just made me think of when I
was like how I'm like I don't want
people to go through what I went through
made me think of that scene in Billy
Madison when a little kid pees his pants
and Billy Madison instead of giving the
businesses like peeing your pants is the
coolest and yeah it makes it look like
he peed his pants too
you see what I'm definitely more that
kind of looks like a superhero if that
happened in real life that guy like that
that's automatic sainthood that's like
the nicest thing anyone could ever do
for someone I thought about that I mean
that's it it was such a good movie you
know what up grateful for Adam Sandler
and Chris Farley any time they were
on-screen together at the same time it's
like it's good as life gets like you
member Chris Farley is the bus driver I
will turn this bus around maybe that's
the funniest thing ever remember what a
barley try to act like he hooked up with
Veronica Vaughn
oh yeah Paulie did that make me laugh
that Veronica rod I mean so like and oh
my gosh those two together so funny
so absolutely funny I'm so grateful for
that
were they ever in a movie together other
than that I'm gonna look it up I know
Chris Farley came out and danced as the
lunch lady in that family video for a
month lady'll and the song I know let's
think it through up maybe Farley within
airheads with Sandler for a little bit
all the Saturday Night Live stuff see
I'm gonna have to go back and look at
some old guy I was never really into
Sandler on SNL any of that so I just saw
his movies I'm after I mean I would love
to watch ugh a music video for one of
his songs how amazing would that be yes
the absolute that it was good times like
those guys together were really really
cool and you know what kids man I think
I'm grateful for when David Spade comes
to the comedy store I don't talk to him
I just stare at him out of the corner of
my eye so grateful for the boozy Tommy
Boy
Tommy Bowie I absolutely Chris Farley
the absolute best so grateful that he
shared his talent with the world is
Tommy boy your favorite do you think
yeah yeah sad man in the world coat will
always get me one of the funniest things
a long time I sometimes get sad because
I think like I love one of my favorite
comedies of all time another one I'm
grateful for is old school
I think that's like one of the best
movies ever but in the back of my brain
I always go I love Will Ferrell and he's
great as Frank the tank but if there was
a way Chris Farley was still alive and
he could play Frank the tank from old
school the thing you get to do that I
think you get to do that in heaven I
think like when you're waiting eater and
you're in God's lobby he's I here grab
some popcorn and hit play like what is
it I've seen old school and then st.
Peter goes not like this and then it's
Chris Farley Frank the tank
you just get to recast the movies the
way you wanted to see them yes
Oh heaven sounds amazing I would totally
go some days you would kill in that in
that role as y'all and Frank the tank
movie like be so so awesome you're gonna
be actually that's why you're working so
hard now and like in heaven Hollywood
you're going to be the big you're going
to be a super big shot but look you just
made like a multi-billion dollar movie
it's going to be the hit of heaven
heaven hell with that's funny oh so
funny oh you know what else I'm sorry
for hogging all the glad acute stuff but
guess what I'm going to be at the Denver
Comedy Works in August oh cool found out
yesterday would you know what anybody's
get your tickets it's the 10th 11th and
12th I think that had a comedy works at
downtown Denver so oh and I'm also
grateful we're going to be in Atlantic
City with uncle Joey in July so it's
going to be the best summer ever dad's
awesome it and then they go to awesome
Steve calm to get tickets no but they
keep the canopic you guys I don't have
my act together loot literally is oh
yeah all the people use the Amazon like
off off interview Thank You Lee you know
what I just got a text from Ari he's
here I love you guys thank you so much
for listening a good times
Lee you're the best thank you for making
this possible and be sure to check out
Joseph's new comedy album take care and
God bless
have a great week guys
[Music]
yesterday was that you can't raise a
baby
[Music]
get drunk
[Applause]
[Music]
you